endeavor thank you well thank you mr.
president for your leadership of this
bold and historic initiative the
department defense is very excited and
committed to working closely with our
partners at HHS across the government
and in the private sector to accomplish
the mission we have begin given winning
matters and we will deliver by the end
of this year a vaccine at scale to treat
the American people and our partners
abroad you know the department defense
has been in this fight since day one
going back to January we've stayed ahead
of the curve every step of the way and
today on America's streets across the
nation over 60,000 servicemembers from
all branches of the service are still
out there whether it's doctors and
nurses and hospitals whether it's
national guard on the streets of America
or the Corps of Engineers continue to
build out capacity in America's
hospitals we are there and we will be
there mr. president and we look forward
to this next greatest phase of this
fight against the corona virus we are
all in then we are all in now and we
will be all in in the future and we will
deliver on time bring it to full weight
to bear the full weight of the
department defense all of our
first-class world-class researchers and
scientists our ability to manage
logistics at scale and our great
distributional capabilities we will
deliver we will win this fight and mr.
president thank you again for all that
you've done we will get the job done I
know you will any questions please go
ahead
[Music]
we think we're going to have a vaccine
in the pretty near future and if we do
we're gonna really be a big step ahead
and if we don't we're going to be like
so many other cases where you had a
problem come in it'll go away at some
point it'll go away
it may flare up and it may not flare up
we'll have to see what happens but if it
does flare up we're gonna put out the
fire
and we'll put it out quickly and
efficiently we've learned a lot Steve
you have a question the vaccine
typically would take 12 to 18 months
well they started actually I guess you
heard in January early January and
they've been working on it I've I know
so many and private companies have been
working on it the government's been
working on it
so we've got the time because we put it
there and they've literally been working
24 hours a day so we've got we've got
the time and we hope to be able to do
something by the end of the year or
shortly thereafter but again you know
it's not solely vaccine based other
things have never had a vaccine and they
go away
so I don't want people to think that
this is all dependent on vaccine but a
vaccine would be a tremendous thing and
I will tell you therapeutically or
therapeutics what's going on there is
equally as impressive we have some
things happening you know we have the
rendus of our from Gilead we have other
things that are very good I think that a
lot is happening happening
therapeutically I can't say that it's
relatively speaking equal to what's
going on with vaccines but I think it's
it's doing very well very well
so therapeutics are a big factor yeah to
develop this vaccine like if France
develops at first will they share it
with us
yeah if and we have that very well
worked out whoever gets it is going to
be very proud to give it and and develop
it they've developed it and we'll see
what happens we've got countries that
are allies that are we have some
countries
actually that aren't allies where we're
working very closely together so we're
working together with many different
countries and again we have no ego
we have no ego whoever gets it we think
it's great we're going to work with them
they're gonna work with us likewise if
we get it we're gonna be working with
them so it's very important very good
question actually yep Lister what do you
say to those business owners and other
people who are really questioning the
guidance that the CDC put out last night
there was a concern that it would be
overly prescriptive now there's our
concern it's not prescriptive enough
what our business owners to do well I
thought the guidance was very good I've
heard very good reviews on the guidance
and you know the media will never be
satisfied if we gave you more
description that would be no good if we
gave you less that would be no good but
I thought it was very good and I've
heard a lot of good things go ahead
please Green
no Abbot's are great it's a great test
it's a very quick test and it can always
be very rapidly double-checked if you're
testing positive or negative it could
always be double-checked but it's a very
good test very portable very quick okay
vaccine what happens if it's China well
the u.s. still have access to that
vaccine I would say the answer to that
would be yes I would say the answer
would be yes yes go ahead please for the
entire partially or a partially approved
vaccine with emergency you know we're
looking for a full vaccine for everyone
that wants to get it not everybody's
going to want to get it but we're
looking at a full vaccine is that a
correct so the answer is the answer is
yes we're working for a fully approved
vaccine but we'll also use the tools we
have for instance emergency use
authorization as appropriate we use all
of our regulatory tools to bring vaccine
available for the entire American
population by January clarified why are
some of you wearing a mask and why are
some of you not wearing a mask
we've all been tested I've been tested
we've open tested and we're quite a
distance away and we're outdoor so I
told them I gave them the option that
they could wear it or not so you can
blame it on me but I gave them the
option we could wear it or not yeah
please well the US vaccine be available
to the rest of the world at an
affordable rate at a low cost
the last thing anybody's looking for is
profit in terms of what we're doing
every company they want to get it at
we've had that we've had a great
experience on Randy so far we've had a
great experience and everything we've
done people are looking to come up with
the answer they're not looking and you
know typically they're saying oh how
much am I going to make how much they
really have been there's been a great
spirit on this they want to get to the
bottom of it and I think we'll be able
to do that the Indian American community
is appreciating your help in in fighting
the vexing corner fighters what is the
process to those 4 million Indian
nations here so India has been so great
and as you know your your Prime Minister
has been a very good friend of mine I
just got back a short while ago from
India recently and we're working very
much with India to and we have a
tremendous Indian population in the
United States and many of the people
that you're talking about are working on
the vaccine - great scientists and
researchers yeah we're working very
closely also with India correct and say
hello to your Prime Minister
yeah please good what steps if any is
your administration taking to ensure
that the communities and the states that
are hardest hit will have first access
to the vaccine have these discussions
been had or are there any plans I think
we've done a good job with that certain
areas have been hit very hard New York
New Jersey etcetera etcetera you know
working very closely with the governor's
we've worked with all of the governors
we've made a lot of people look very
good with what we've done on ventilators
with what we've done on testing we're
working with all of the governor's we
just sent a big transit package to New
Jersey I just spoke to the governor of
New Jersey who is a
a terrific person by the way I have to
tell you and I just told them a lot of
money's coming your way for the transit
and also I spoke with the governor of
New York Governor Cuomo we just had a
conversation yesterday we're sending
them a lot of Transportation money so
it's important but we've had a very good
relationship working with all of the
states regardless all of the states and
if we do get fortunate enough and I
think we're skilled enough but fortunate
enough to have a vaccine it'll get out
fairly and quickly do you foresee that
states that our hardest hit will have
first dip so we'll like New York and New
Jersey I think that makes sense perhaps
you know perhaps it does but you know I
would say probably but I think they're
all gonna get well distributed you know
if you remember where we started we had
no ventilators we had to make them and
we became a very major manufacturer of
ventilators now we're helping countries
all over the world with ventilators
we're sending them to many countries all
over the world when we started we didn't
have ventilators we I inherited nothing
I inherited practically nothing from the
previous administration unfortunately
yeah go ahead mr. president it's been
three months since you signed the China
trade deal between what's happened with
coronavirus and the lagging agricultural
purchases are you at any point
considering reimposing additional
tariffs on China or tearing up the deal
in any other way well I don't want to
talk about it I can say China is buying
a lot of our product but the trade deal
the ink was barely dry when this came in
from China so it's not like with
thrilled okay go ahead
please mr. president can I ask one more
I'm wondering if you're standing by the
nomination of Michael Pak to leave Voice
of America after news but the DC
Attorney General well I don't know what
happened I know that Voice of America is
run in a terrible manner terrible and
they're not the voice of America they're
the opposite of the voice of America and
we have a man who is very good I don't
know he's in the nominating process but
I'll have to check that out yeah please
Thank You miss president if public
confidence is the main thing of getting
people back to work and back to schools
and so on is this even possible without
a vaccine how would it be possible
without a vaccine public confidence well
I think a very big factor frankly is
that very few people are you know we
read about all of the very sad very
tragic I've lost friends many of us have
lost friends we read about that and we
see that and that's what the news covers
but a very very splits a very small
percentage it's a very very small
percentage I say it all the time it's a
tiny percentage the vast majority many
people don't even know they have it they
have it or they have sniffles or they
have a very minor side and they recover
not only recover they probably have
immunity whether it's your term long
term but they have probably immunity and
I think people have to understand that
that's why I think the school should be
back in the fall I think that lots of
things should happen I don't think that
you should have 70 year old teachers
back yet they should wait till
everything is gone I don't think you
should have a professor that 65 and has
diabetes or has a bad heart back
necessarily or somebody that's older
than that but we want to see our schools
back we want to see our country start to
work again we created the greatest
economy in the history of the world and
we're going to do it again and you're
going to see that next year and it's
going to start you'll start to see it in
the fourth quarter maybe even before
that yeah so are you at all concerned
about children or teachers who are in
the in the school bringing it home to
their families there's best I'm
concerned about everything and I'm also
concerned about our country our country
has to get back and you know what you're
talking is when you are doing what we
did with the shutdown that causes death
also it causes massive depression
it causes drugs it causes suicide it
causes a lot of problems also know our
country has to get back to work again
and you see that just looking and
reading everything that's happening or
people want to get back they want to get
back
sir do you have a plan to prevent the
spread if you if you really we do we do
we have a great plan to prevent the
spread but that doesn't mean we're gonna
close our country for five years okay
not gonna happen
go ahead death toll is about 86,000 at
current it's about 86,000 yes do you
think that's accurate or do you think
it's higher than that I don't were lower
than that I don't know I don't know I
those are the numbers that are being
reported I assume they're correct unlike
other countries I mean you have some
countries obviously you have some that
are very obviously ridiculous but our
numbers are accurate numbers we don't do
anything with the numbers one way or the
other whatever it is that's what we do
we take the numbers as reported okay oh
I don't know I don't know if they were
I'd be very happy if they were lower I'd
like to see numbers lower I'd like to
see no death at all one death as too
many this should have never happened
this came from China it should have been
stopped in China before it got out to
the world we have 186 that's been
updated this morning 186 countries are
affected and each country that's
affected is the same thing Russia now is
badly affected France is badly affected
you look at what each country and you
could say affected or you can say
infected either way you want to put it
but you look at these countries look at
Italy and you look at Spain and you look
at all of these great countries in many
cases how they've how they've had a
fight through this it's a terrible thing
that happened it could have been stopped
at the source it should have been
stopped right at the source but it
wasn't thank you all very much we
appreciate it thank you thank you
[Music]